the president's first pandemic briefing
since April a bid to reassert control of
America's growing crisis thank you very
much for the most part Donald Trump
stuck to script coming apart more in the
questions from journalists just Lane
Maxwell is in prison and so a lot of
people want to know she's going to turn
in powerful people do you feel that
she's going to turn into powerful men
how do you see that working out I don't
know I haven't really been following it
too much I just wish her well frankly
I've met her numerous times over the
years especially since I lived in Palm
Beach and I guess they lived in Palm
Beach ghilane Maxwell is accused of sex
trafficking underage girls for the late
convicted sex offender Jeffrey Epstein
charges she denies and intends to fight
the president is among several
well-known people linked to the pair the
intent of this briefing was to provide
an update on what Donald Trump
repeatedly called the China virus more
than a thousand people died of covert 19
in America yesterday the highest number
since the second of June California is
now poised to surpass New York in case
numbers and states like Texas and
Florida have seen hospitals overwhelmed
certainly the president struck a more
somber tone than recent days some areas
of our country are doing very well
others are doing less well it will
probably unfortunately get worse before
it gets better
as the virus has surged in parts of
America Donald Trump's approval ratings
have gone in the opposite direction this
comes as a poll shows 60% of Americans
don't think he's doing a good job of
handling the crisis Donald Trump
pressured States to reopen even when the
infection rate was still on the rise in
many parts of the country his focus was
getting the battered economy back on
track over containing the virus but one
can't come without the other
now with just 15 weeks to go until the
election he's looking to gain a
television audience with the virus
keeping him off the campaign trail after
tweeting this photograph on
the president is now endorsing face
masks to help save lives in a bid to
save his presidency his newly reinstated
briefings perhaps a more risky measure
Sally Lockwood Sky News Washington